Hallo ihr Lieben!
Ich hab mir gedacht die Banana Split Torte die kam so gut bei euch an,
lass ich mir nochmal etwas mit Bananen einfallen.
Und ich hab heute etwas für euch, das ist "No Bake",
also der Ofen bleibt aus.
Und es ist total raffiniert, also wenn ihr das serviert,
werden eure Gäste sagen: "Wow was ist das denn? Richtig cool!"
Ich zeig euch jetzt zuallererst den "Teig", ich sag euch gleich warum
aber dafür benötigen wir folgende 2 Zutaten:
zum einen sind das diese Löffelbiskuits und zum anderen etwas Milch.
Wichtig für den nächsten Schritt ist, dass ihr euch ein großes Schneidebrett nehmt
oder irgendwas, was groß ist, breit ist und in euren Kühlschrank passt,
das ist auch ganz wichtig.
Und darüber gebt ihr zwei Mal Frischhaltefolie, sodass ihr eine richtig schöne lange Fläche habt.
Jetzt nehmen wir uns unsere Löffelbiskuits,
tunken sie für eine Sekunde in die Milch
und geben sie dann mit der Zuckerseite nach unten auf unser Schneidebrett.
Sobald ihr eine Reihe vollständig habt mit 12 Löffelbiskuits,
gebt ihr die anderen 12 Löffelbiskuits eine Reihe darunter.
So, fertig. Und jetzt geben wir Frischhaltefolie da drüber
und anschließend kommt das in den Kühlschrank für mindestens 2 1/2 bis 3 Stunden
und dann zeig ich euch, wie's weiter geht.
Und nach der Kühlzeit der Löffelbiskuits machen wir weiter mit unserer Füllung, also der Creme
und dafür zeige ich euch jetzt die Zutaten.
Zum einen benötigen wir natürlich Bananen, außerdem kalte Schlagsahne
Magerquark, Mascarpone, Puderzucker,
ein paar Schoko-Drops und Sahnestandmittel.
Für die Creme verwende ich jetzt die Küchenmaschine, ihr könnt
natürlich auch euer Handrührgerät verwenden.
Und ich mach das immer so, dass ich Mascarpone und Magerquark zusammen
mit Sahne und Puderzucker in die Schüssel gebe und anschließend
schlage ich das so ein bisschen, etwa eine halbe Minute,
dass sich das verbindet und dann zeig ich euch, wie's weitergeht.
Nach etwa 30 Sekunden geben wir unser Sahnestandmittel mit hinzu,
schlagen das schön auf höchster Stufe, und dann merkt ihr schon,
dass die Sahne steif wird und ihr ne richtig schöne, feste Creme erhaltet.
So, nach 1-2 Minuten ist die Creme auch schon fertig, jetzt
geb ich noch die Schoko-Drops hinein.
Ihr könnt natürlich statt der Schoko-Drops auch ganz andere Sachen rein tun,
wie zum Beispiel..was gibt's denn da Hamza?
Kokosraspeln passen ganz gut zu Bananen oder was ich auch finde, Himbeeren.
Himbeeren und Bananen sind eine tolle Mischung also gerne
Tiefkühl-Heimbeeren reingeben, aber ich bleib heute
bei den Schoko-Drops.
Jetzt wird die Torte nur noch zusammengestellt, dafür
zieh ich zuallererst die obere Frischhaltefolie von
den Löffelbiskuits ab.
Und dann geben wir unsere Creme da drauf.
Wichtig ist, dass ihr oben und unten so ungefähr 2cm frei lasst,
damit wir das später richtig schön aufwickeln können.
Sobald ihr die Creme verstrichen habt, gebt ihr Bananen drauf
auf das untere Drittel, und ich mag es immer,
wenn die Bananen schon richtig schön braun sind.
Wie seht ihr das denn? Das würd mich mal sehr interessieren
Weil da spalten sich ja wirklich die Geister!
Bananen lieber wenn sie braun sind, dann sind sie ein bisschen süßer,
oder mögt ihr sie, wenn sie noch richtig grün sind?
Ich mag das ja garnicht.
Und es kommt immer drauf an, wie groß die Bananen sind,
ich brauche jetzt 2 1/2.
Geb sie jetzt hier wie gesagt auf das untere Drittel
und dann rollen wir das Ganze ein.
Und die Bananenrolle ist eigentlich schon fertig, jetzt fehlt nur noch die Deko.
Dafür hab ich mir ein bisschen von der Creme zur Seite gegeben
und in eine ganz große Sterntülle getan, damit auch die Schoko-Drops durch passen
und jetzt werd ich sie noch abschließend dekorieren.
Das Besondere an der Bananenrolle ist, dass sie so schön weich ist,
die Löffelbiskuits sind richtig schön soft.
Natürlich könnt ihr sie auch in andere Flüssigkeiten tränken, gerne auch Kaffee
aber ich hab gedacht heute mal kinderfreundlich
und sie schmeckt wunderbar mit diesen Schoko-Drops dazwischen.
Da hat man so einen richtig schönen Crunch noch
und falls ihr das Ganze am Vortag zubereiten möchtet:
funktioniert auch wunderbar.
Ich schreib euch wie immer die genauen Zutaten hier unten in die Infobox.
Macht's gerne nach!
Hinterlasst dem Video ein Däumchen nach oben und
ein Abo, dann verpasst ihr auch nichts mehr und im Anschluss
verlink ich euch auch noch die Banana Split Torte, die so gut bei euch ankam,
da hab ich ja über Instagram ganz viele Fotos von euch bekommen.
Macht das gerne auch wieder, ich freu mich immer sehr,
eure Fotos anzuschauen und freu mich,
wenn ihr beim nächsten Mal auch wieder dabei seid.
Auf Wiedersehen, Tschüss!